では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはブッダの意志と強化
意志強化実ということになります
で ちょっと内容は複雑になる可能性ありますけど
一応は勉強してみましょう
まず我々はチェータナという言葉を学んだ方がよろしいですね
テーラワーダ チェータナ
これはまあ日本語で意思でしょうね
英語でウェルかインテンションという言葉に訳するんですね
行動を引き起こす心の働き
我々の心の中はちょっと微妙な働きがありまして
そこにいろんな行動を引き起こすんですね
すべての心に常にある
これを心所というんですね
これは仏教専門用語でチェータスカ
で どんな生命にも 動物も誰でもね
心あるものにはこの意志
チェータナというものがあるんですね
それが心に入って心を活動させるんですね
心の仕事っていうのは
まず何か認識することなんですけどね
だから我々は歩いたり座ったりするときにも
やっぱりまず認識して
それから認識の指令によって歩いたり座ったりするんですね
だから心の指令で体を動かしているんですね
だから体を動かすためにも心が指令を出さなくちゃないし
その前に物事を知っておかなくちゃいけないんですね
体を動かす前に いわゆる歩く前に
どこに歩くのかとか ちょっと状況判断しなくちゃいけない
そういうすべての仕事は心がやっていて
この仕事をさせる力はチェータナと意志というんですね
心の次の進化に変化させる働きなので
不安定ポテンシャルだとも理解することができます
心っていうのは この光よりも早く
ものすごく変化していくんですね
変わって変わって 新しい心になっていくんです
その新しい心に だから今の心が死んじゃって
次の瞬間に新しい心が生まれるんです
その新しい心を作るちゃうんですね
だからそれがこの大体
このチェータナの力なんですね
だからチェータナっていうのはなんか落ち着いてないんですね
だからそこをすぐ壊して
次の心を作るんですね
だから その一つの心を壊して
次の心を作るって その働き
まあ普通意志ですからね
その言葉で だから不安定みたいなもんなんですね
それに認識の中になんか不安定みたいなものがありまして
あるいはポテンシャルでもよろしいんですね
そこで次のものが生まれてくるんですね
で それから意志と物質の関係を考えてみましょう
物質も不安定という特徴を持っているので
常に変化をし続けています
しかし 意志はない この宇宙にあるすべての物質にも
原子一個見ても それ素粒子みたいなものを見ても
どんなものもなんか不安定を持ってるんですね
不安定があるんだから
次々次々転がって変わっていくんです
だから この素粒子の領域って
そんなのはもう理解するのはややこしくて難しいんだからね
例えば 地震が起きると
なんで建物揺れるのかというと
やっぱり地震によって地球が不安定になりますから
大地が不安定になるんだから
その建物が揺れちゃうんですね
で なんで建物が壊れるのかというと
やっぱり安定した 位置に戻りたいんですね
戻るんですかね 変わりたいんですね
だから このステージの上にね
ビー玉を置いたら ビー玉が転がっていくならば
ビー玉が置いたところで不安定なんですね
ですから転がっていくんで
転がってどこかで止まるんですね
地球ってところ すごい大雑把な例で考えれば
しかし 素粒子で考えちゃうと
これは永久的に止まらないんですね
ずっと転げっぱなしなんですね
ですから この物質もずっと変化しているんです
例えば鉄という元素があるとしましょう
この鉄 例えば地球であろうか
宇宙であろうか 鉄という元素がずっと同じスピードで変化していくんです
ですから 地球から鉄を一歩取って
宇宙のどこから鉄を取って比較したっても
同じスピードで変化しているんです
宇宙的に考えると そういうわけで
この物質もずっともう変化してして
過ぎ過ぎ 過ぎ過ぎていくんですね
やがてすべて壊れるでしょう
すべて壊れても不安定があるんだから
またどこか転がって転がっていくんですね
それは仏教用語で無常ということになるんですね
すべての現象はそういう不安定というものを持っていて
不安定というのは 私がわかりやすくするために使っている単語ですけど
まあなんでしょうかね
これを専門的に言えばね
あんまり科学知りませんから
あまりのところじゃないんですけど
あまりと言っちゃうと
なんかちょっと知ってるようなふりをしますけどね
全然知らないんだけど
だからこの物質もずっと変わっていくんですね
私たちはそこはなかったことにするだけなんですね
まあ例えば鉄はすぐ錆びますけどね
まあアルミで作りましょうよと
台所をね 鉄板よりアルミの方がよろしいと
アルミは変化しないとか思ってるんですね
それはもう我々のそう思っているだけで
ずっとそれ自身の世界ではもう変化していくんですね
しかし 物質には意思がないんですね
意思がないんだから 例えば何でしたっけ？ハイリジェン
何でしたっけ？水素元素を見たら
水素元素の中に何の意思もないんです
水素原子がある法則で変化していくんですね
だから物質の変化っていうのは
その気になれば科学者に調べやすいんですね
なぜかというと パターンが一定しているんです
一定しているんです で
変わらないんです 変化するんだけど
なんか変わらないとおかしいんですね
だから ある一定のパターンでずっと変化していくんです
私たち知ってる世界ではね
例えば鉄は変化するスピードがあって
アルミは変化するスピードあるように見えますけど
本当は原子のところで見たら
もうどっちでも結局は原子ですからね
そちらの変化スピードは同じになるんですね
それで意志が入っちゃうと違うんですよ
生命には物質の不安定も心の不安定も
いわゆる意志もあるので
変化の流れが複雑なんです
物質はすごい丁寧なパターンで変化していきますが
速くなることもないし
スピードを下げることもないんです
丁寧に変化していくんです
で 心が割り込んでくると
そこはすごく複雑なんです
で 心が入ると我々は変化の道を変えるんですね
例えば 買ってきた野菜は
今夏ですからね すぐ悪くなっちゃうんですね
我々冷蔵庫に放り込んじゃうんですね
そこで意図的に人間がキャベツの変化のキャベツも一つ有機物ですから
早く壊れますけど そこはちょっとスピード
人間の心を使って そこをスピードスローダウンさせてもらうんですね
あまりにもスローにすると
キャベツはもう食べられなくなりますよ
石になりますからね 化石みたいなものになりますからね
だからある程度でスローダウンする
で 我々の体っていうのはずっと壊れていくんですね
で 壊れていくんだけど
我々も意思でご飯食べたり
いろんなものしたりして
修復して修復して 変化の方向性とスピードをもうハチャメチャ変えているんです
意思だけは強化することはできます
そこでこの今日は意思の強化ですから
だから何のために強化するんですか？と疑問も出てきますね
意思っていうのは心を持ってる
不安定なんですね これ
何のために強化するんですかね
まあ不安定だから それはちょっとレベル上げることはできます
これでいいんでしょうかっていうね
で 不安定の程度が上がると
さっとそれ壊れて次のステップに行くんですね
安定を求めて次のステップに行く
それでも不安定だったら
また次のステップに変化する
この意思 意思とすごいかっこいい意味というかね
みんなポジティブ的な意味意味で考えてるみたいですけど
これ心の不安定なんですね
それから次のステップに変化するんだから
それにはエネルギーが必要なんですよ
だからそのエネルギーも意志そのものなんです
だから私はポテンシャルということも使ったんですね
次どんな姿になるのかっていうことは
今の心が自分持っているポテンシャルで決めなくてはいけないんですね
このテーブルからね ガラスが落ちると割れるかもしれませんし
ペットボトルが落ちても割れないというね
だから割れるか割れないかっていうことは
その品物を持ってるポテンシャルによります
まあとにかく意志は強化することはできます
しかし 意志で意志を強化するんですね
ちょっと引っかかる問題がありまして
強化するということは変化させることなんですね
状況を変化させるんですね
だからだったら これ意志がやらなくちゃいかんですね
意志が自分を強くしなくちゃいけないんです
これは理論的なものですから
実践的にはちょっとこれ無理ということになるんですね
意志に勝手に意志を強化することができれば
もうどこまででも強くなっちゃうんですよ
まあ例えばボールペンの中に物質がありまして
もういっぱい素粒子が溜まってるもので
エネルギー持ってますね
不安定でしょ このボールペン自体がどんどん自分の不安定の状況を強化していくこと
これ怖いもんですよ 制限ないんだから
そうすると電子爆弾になっちゃうかもしれません
ボールペンでしたけど
あまりにもエネルギー溜まっちゃうとね
しかし 物質の場合はそれはもうないんです
自分であえてエネルギーをどんどん強化しようということは不可能です
できない 心にはできるんですね
それも理論ですよ 理論上はできるんです
で 意志がもっと強くならなくちゃあかんよと思ったら
強くなります そうすると次の心の変化っていうのは
結構大変な変化になります
そこでさらに強くならなくちゃいけないと思っちゃうと
さらに大胆な変化になってしまいます
ということはね 意志は自動生産して力強くなるという話になりましたね
これ本当にできるのかと
論理だけなんですね 意志を強化したいという
まず意志が必要ですね
で ある程度我々にもできます
意志を強化しなくちゃいかないという意志を作ったら
意志がある程度で強くなっていくんです
だから人の話を聞いたってもダメですよ
もっと強い意志を持ちなさいよと
ではなくて 自分がもっと意志を
自分の心がね 意志を何といいますか
発見して あ これが意志ですと
あ これはもうもうちょっと強化した方がいいという意志になったら
次の心には強い意志の意志が入っているんですね
論理的に無限に強化できるはずですが
何事にもリミットがあります
結局は そう見てみると
意志は意志で意志を強化するならば
外から何もいらないんですね
自動生産でどんどんもう無限に意志の力が広くなっちゃいますけどね
大きくなりますけど それはもう論理だけで
現実はそうじゃないんですね
リミットがあります どんなものにも
様々な因縁も絡んできます
いろんな因縁が絡んできて
そこはもう混乱します
皆様方はこの最近の生物学のね
遺伝子の世界をね ずっと勉強してみると
遺伝子の変化の中にもそういうふうな
まあいろんな原因が絡み合ってね
ただ 遺伝子はコピーするだけじゃないんですね
科学者にはいまだに理解できない仕事を結構やっています
はい これで話にまた内容に入ります
基本的なチェータナ ベーシックウェルですね
これが善でもない 悪でもない
生命の基本的な生きたいという症状です
衝動です で ここをなんで説明するのかというと
意志が意志で意志を強化することができますけど
意志って何ですかね これよくわからないんですね
だから掴めないものはね
ちょっと管理できないんですね
だから仏教心理学では
それはなんとかわかってもらうようにはするんです
しかし それでもわからないと思います
この意志そのものは善でも悪でもないんです
ただ不安定だけなんです
で 私的にわかりやすく言えば
生命っていうのは生きたいんですね
意志は別にこのまま変化しないでいたいとは思わないんですね
意志はないんだからね
だから物体はどうにも問題なく
すごく丁寧に自然法則によって変化していくんですよ
これ 生命になってくると
生きていきたい 生きていきたい
生きていきたいというエネルギーがあるんです
それが意志なんです そういうことで
ご自分が持っている意志を発見してください
意志のこのベーシック
一番ベーシックな顔 姿
生きていきたいという気持ちですね
なかなか気づかないでしょ
生きていきたいという気持ちにも
ひどい目に遭わない限りはね
例えばがんになったりとかね
すごい病気になって これはちょっと治療は難しいですよ
できませんよと言われると
さっと気づくんですね
ああ 自分がずっと死にたくないということでいたんだと
だから死なないというごまかしやっていたんだと
生きていきたいということが
我々はごまかしてるんですね
我は死なないという幻覚で
そこで医者がね 我は死なないという幻覚を破っちゃうんですよ
病気になったところでね
心臓に問題があったり
がん細胞を発生したり
いろいろ出てくると 医者がそれを言わなくちゃあかんですね
医者に言われたら別に驚かなくてもいいんですよ
現状を説明するだけだから
我々は驚くんですね びっくりするんですね
なぜかというと 我々はずっとまやかしで生きてきたんですね
我は死なないという そこは壊れてしまいますね
その壊れた瞬間で意志に気づくんですね
ああ 生きていきたいんだと
この生きていきたいという
あの衝動が意志です 生きるために必要とされる様々な行為を引き起こす衝動になります
それで生きていきたいんだから
呼吸していますし ご飯も食べているし
勉強もするし 建物も作るしね
言語も習うし 人間関係も持つし
あらゆることをしますね
いわゆる生きているんですね
そこを全部裏でやらせているのはこの意志なんです
人間として生きるためには勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから勉強は生きるためなんですね
だから生きていきたいという気持ちが勉強させてくれるんですね
人間としてはやっぱり住む家がなければダメですね
そうすると 心が心の中にある意志が働き出しちゃって
家を作らせるんです そこで意志には自分勝手に行動はできませんね
例えば 私は私の意志で家を作りたいと
まあとにかくせっかく作るんだから
まあ 5階の５階もある家にしましょう
かっこいいだろうと それはいいんだけど
自分の体では作れないんですね
意志があっても そう簡単には思い浮かばない
たくさん条件が入ってくる
あたり金があるのか 土地があるのか
ある土地で 5階まで建物を建てられるのか
どんな建築家に頼むのかとかね
どんな業者に頼むのかとかね
そういういろんなことを絡んできて
そこである結果になります
そのなった結果はに対して意志が満足するかしないかは別なんです
いつでもそうでしょう
我々は満足できてないでしょう
ここで皆様に理解していただきたいのは
あの意志というパワーが生きるということを起こしてるんだと
だから今私はちょっとここら辺触っていたんですが
意志があったんです 触りたいと
意志がなかったらその仕事はしないんです
まぶたが閉じることさえも意志があって起こるんです
生きている体の中に起こる全ての仕事が意志があって起こるんで
だから意志には勝手にできません
だから 細胞たちがいろんな機械を作るんですね
世の中に出来上がる機械の中で
一番効率の良い機械っていうのは体なんですね
自然に出来上がる機械だから
無駄なものはまずないんです
だから人間には体ほど...人間だけじゃなくて
動物 誰の体でも同じことですけど
あの それほど完全な機械は作れません
完全っていうのおかしい単語ですけどね
いわゆる無駄のない 効率が一番ピーク
ヘビがすごく長いでしょう
でもそれも立派な完全に近い機械なんです
問題ないんです で 足がないでしょ
でも動かなくちゃいかんですね
ちゃんと動くようにシステムができてるんですね
ヘビは全身で動けるようになっているんです
で それで この遺伝子の変化によって体のいろんな機械が出来上がるし
だからといって遺伝子に
遺伝子だけ勝手に遺伝子というのはアミノ酸だから
アミノ酸だけ物質的に働くならば
誰の体でも完璧な体になるはずなんです
しかし 残念ながら遺伝子がタンパク質を作る時でも
なんかどこかでそこをコントロールしちゃうんですね
足がもうちょっと伸びた方がバランスいいのに伸ばしてくれないとかね
まあ人間が考える体はもう本当に屁理屈ですけど
生物学者が言ってる理想的な体っていうのは結構太っていて
背が短くなければダメなんですね
で なんか立って安静にして立てないんですね
だから我々は今 自然のバランスを壊して細くなっちゃって
背が高くなっちゃって
すごい不安定な状態なんです
なんかヘビが立ってるような感じで
で これでダメージ受けますけどね
で ある生物学者書いた
この科学的に正しい体は何ですかと言ったら
書きますけど 皆様はみんな嫌がりますよと言って書いてあったんですけど
かなり太いんですね 短い
あまり背が高くないんです
で 周りが結構大きいんです
だからそのスケッチ見て
あ これはすごい安定した安定した体に私にも見えましたけど
でもかっこ悪いと 現代的な美的な感覚から見ればえらいかっこ悪い
はい それで私が言いたいのは
この遺伝子は純粋タンパク質であるとアミノ酸であるというならば
アミノ酸は他外からアミノ酸を入れたりして
自分で新しいアミノ酸を作ればいいって話でしょうに
それだったら大体完全な体作るはずなんですけど
どこかでブレーキかかってるんですね
だから しっかりしたものを見る目が必要ですけど
まあなかなかこれバラバラ
聴覚があった方がいいのに
なかなかそこも能力バラバラで
体の形にしても色にしても
まあ結構管理されてるんですね
いわゆる我々の好みの通りにいかないってことはよくわかるでしょう
肉体は我々の好みの通りにはいかないんですね
好みっていうのは一つ意志なんですけど
意志が思ってもポテンシャルでもありますから
同時に ポテンシャルというのはどれぐらい財産を持っているのかっていう話でしょ
だから意志は自分持っているポテンシャルで次の変化をしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから決めちゃう カバン買いたいとデパートに行っても
どんなカバン買えるのかっていうことで
自分の財布にある札 お金の枚数で決められますからね
欲しいのはわかるんだけど
何でも買えるわけじゃない
気に入ってるカバンがあるのもわかるんだけど
だからといってどんなカバンにするのかっていうことは
財布が決めてくれるんですね
ということは そのカバンを買いたくデパートに行った人のポテンシャルなんですね
財布っていうのは そういうことで
まあ意志自分自身で気に入らなくなっているんだけど
知ったことじゃないんですよ
例えば私は私の体は気に入らないんですけど
でも自分の意志が作ったものですね
意志が自分持っているポテンシャルで
だから気に入らないということはちょっと余計なんですよ
余計ですけど どんな生命もそう思っているんです
動物はあまりないみたいですけどね
我々人間が自分の体には完璧に満足しませんね
もうちょっとこうなったら
ああなった方がいいんじゃないかなと思っちゃうんですね
これは本当の答えを言えば
知ったことじゃないんだよっていう答えなんですよ
金も持ってないくせにね
豪邸作りたがってるんだから
これはなりたくないんですからね
だからそこら辺理解して落ち着いた方がいいんですよ
落ち着かないんですね
これ仏教用 仏教が語る業
カンマも意志というポテンシャルなんですね
これで仏教用語になってくると
皆様よく知っているカルマ
カンマという言葉ありますね
業という 業っていうのは意志のことなんです
チェータナのことなんです
だから意志っていうのは
ちょっと二重 程度の二重構造で働くみたいですね
意志が次の瞬間 今の瞬間を壊して次の瞬間を作る
作りたいという意志があって
それはいいんだけど 次の瞬間どんな形にするのかっていうことは
今の意志が持っているポテンシャルに依存するんです
依存でしたっけ？ディペンド
まあそれによる によるんですね
なんか難しいですね 知ったことないです
もう これはもう事実です
簡単にすることはちょっと難しい
意志は単独で働かない
それでお釈迦様の世界になってくると
お釈迦様がこういうのを精密に発見しているんですね
今 皆様と一緒に私も苦労しましたね
意志を発見するために
私たちは自分の意志に気づかないんですよ
ひどい病気にでも遭わない限り
命が危険やと言われたら
あ 意志で気づくんです
生きていきたいという
お釈迦様それじゃなくてだけではなくて
意志というのは単独で行動できませんと
当たり前ですね 私には億円あっても単独で家作れませんね
だからいろんな原因が絡んで
何か家という結果になるんですね
だから私の希望そのまま家の形になることはあり得ないんです
この家を作る場合でもね
設計して家ものを作ってもらう人がね
よく話し合うでしょう
設計書きながら だから建築家はもうもう何回も何回も設計図描き直すんですね
一番最初にもう お客さんがね
あのやっぱり家はつぐらい必要やと
４つで３つぐらいでもバスルーム
アタッシュバスタブも入ってほしいとかね
シャワーもあってねとかね
偉そうなことを言うんですね
そこでマスターバスルームやらあったりしてね
よくわかりましたと さっさと書くんですね
これどれぐらいなりますかと
まあこれだったら 10億円ぐらいになりますよと
10億円はないんだから 1億しかないんだよと
それだったらどうしましょうかと
また話し合うんですね
そうすると いやいや いやいやで部屋の数を減らす
それでも値段は下がらない
では どんな部屋にもバスルームというのはやめましょうよと
１か所で全部揃った方が結構制約
何でしたっけ？節約できますよとかね
じゃあしょうがない そうしましょうと
そうやって話し合って話し合って
やっと最終設計図が出来上がっちゃうんですね
そうすると この家を建てて欲しかった人の好みは
その通りに行ってないんです
それで そのたとえで考えてください
我々に意志があっても
意志には単独で結果を出すことはできません
意志が他の因子と一緒になって働くんです
貪瞋痴は基本的な仲間です
で 意志のベーシックフォーム
オリジナルフォームというかね
元の姿が生きていきたいっていう存在欲なんです
仏教用語で言えば渇愛ですね
その目的があって 変化の路線を変えながら変えながら生きてみるんです
長生きする努力をするんだけど
そううまくいかないんですね
年取ります 年取っても何とかして若々しくいたいと頑張っちゃうんですね
だから結局は自然法則から見ればもう迷惑なんですね
人間やってることは 遺伝子に至ってもすごい迷惑なんですね
本当にありゃしなくらい迷惑なんです
皮膚は自然法則によってしわが出てきたり
いろいろ変化します それは一番良い姿なんですよ
我々はしわが出るの嫌なんですね
年取っても皮膚だけは子供の赤ちゃん の皮膚と同じくすやすやしてほしいんですね
こんなこと期待したっても
細胞たちにとってはね
そんなプログラムないんです
まあ遺伝子はもうこれから変わらなくちゃいかんですよ
だから結局我々の意志がね
渇愛がすごい迷惑をかけているんですよ
存在に限りない迷惑をかけているんです
そこで意志っていうのは悪でも善でもないんだけど
これ存在欲が絡んでいるんだからね
あんまり清らかなものであるともと言えないんですね
意志そのものにはただポテンシャルだけでどうったことはない
それに存在欲がついてくるんですね
そうすると汚れるんです
汚れた意志になります
基本的にどんな生命の意志も貪瞋痴
と噛み合わせて形になるんです
人は欲などの感情に気づきますが
意志の存在に気づきません
これで私たちは欲が出てきたら
これ欲ですよとわかるでしょ
でも意志はには気づかないんです
怒ったら同じく俺は怒ったぞとわかるんですよ
意志には気づかないんですね
しかし その時は 例えば欲が上がってくると
意志も上がっているんです
一緒に それで汚れた意志になるんですね
もともと汚れていなかったんです
怒りと組み合うと 怒りの意志になっちゃうんですね
そこで組み合った仲間に合わせて結果出すんです
意志が欲と組み合わせ合わせると
欲に関する行動をするんですね
例えば もう美味しく贅沢に食いたいなと
精神的にチェータナーに欲が入っちゃうと食べまくっちゃうんですね
それは細胞たちにとってはえらい迷惑なんですよ
えらい迷惑ですけど 意志の中に欲が入っちゃったんだからね
これで意志が強くなっちゃったんです
それで食べてしまう 意志の中に怒りが入り込んじゃうと
何か人に悪口言ったり
喧嘩したり 物を壊したり
いろんな行動をするんですね
全体的にはどちらでも生きていることですけど
なんかそれでいいのかっていう問題も出てきますね
例えば怒りが割り込んでくると
破壊的なことをするんですね
破壊的なことをしたら
あなたのベーシックファンダメンタルなニーズはどうなるのかと
生きていきたいということは
これも破壊されてしまいますね
そこで矛盾ということが生まれちゃっちゃうんですね
例えば欲も同じなんですね
欲が入ってくると破壊的なことをしません
しないように見えるだけ
だって食べ過ぎになっちゃっても
それって破壊的でしょ
あまりにもおしゃれに目が行かなくなっちゃうと
これも存在に対しては破壊的なんですよ
ダメージを与えるんですね
あまりにもスマートな体を持ちたいと思っちゃうと
かなり体に無理をさせちゃうんですね
だから欲にしたっても
最終的には生きていきたいっていう目的に対して反対のことをやっちゃうんですね
そういうことで やっぱりそうだって矛盾っていうのは見えてくるんですね
悪い仲間と一緒になると
意志の力は悪業になります
良い仲間と組むと善行になります
で ここら辺からお釈迦様の智慧が開発しているんだから
これから皆様にも理解できると思います
で 普通世界では理解できないすごい難しい心理学ですけどね
お釈迦様のこのものの見事な分析と説明によってわかりやすい
だからお釈迦様 チェータナーハンビッケウェーカンマンワダーミ業とはチェータナーのことであると私は明言しますと言うんですね
言って 悪業善業って何なのかという場合は
貪瞋痴で行う行為は悪業で
不貪不瞋不痴で行う行為は善行であると
その時チェータナーは関係なくなっちゃうんですね
だからチェータナー時代が自体が業なんですけど
これ善か悪か決めるために仲間が必要なんです
そういう風になっちゃうんです
例えば自分が家を造りたいとかね
持っている しかし 建築家のこと一人もわからない
何の知り合いもない そうすると一般的に宣伝している建設業者に業者に頼まなくちゃあかんでしょ
そちらそちらのやり方で既成的なものを組み合わせちゃって
このくらいお金だったらこれぐらいのものしか作ってませんがい
さようなら と 残酷なんですね
もし私にちょっとお金ありまして
家作りたいし これで一流の建築家と友人がいるんですよ
ものすごい仲のいい友達で
友達だから その人と 実はね
俺も家一軒作りたいんだけど
もう困ったもんだ まあまあ
いいやいいや 私はあなたにもう最高なものを造ってあげますよと
言ったら その建築が私が持ってるお金で
もうびっくりするほどの作品を作ってくれるように頑張ってくれるんですね
だから 私の意志が私持っていたお金であるとするならば
そのお金はどんな結果出したかっていうことが
仲間によって決めてしまいます
そういうことで 意志と仲間っていうことを学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
これは仏教では この仲間のことは信条という言葉で専門的に使っています
はい 次のポイント はい
これから皆様勉強するべきところです
意志は単独で強化することもできない
前理論言ったでしょ 私は偉そうに
意志は意志で強化できますよと
あれは理論なんです 問題は意志にアクセスさえもできないんです
意志は行為を惹起するので強化した方が良い
しかし 直接意志にアクセスできません
強化したければ 意志をしっかりと確認して
これが意志ですと わからないと
あの意志に気づくのは
このヴィパッサナー実践やっている方々が
ヴィパッサナーは結構経験を積み重ねて
実況中継かなり上手になってくると
微妙に観察するんですね
微妙に観察すると 意志が働いているのは
その方々はよく発見するんですね
例えば手を上げる場合は
上げる上げる上げると実況するだけじゃなくて
微妙に観察するんですね
微妙に観察すると 上げたいと意志がすーっと流れていく
流れていって手が上がっている
で 意志に気づくんです
これはヴィパッサナー実践以外は意志に気づく方法はないんです
まあ派手な現代的な実験はできますけどもね
例えばとんでもなく怒っちゃう
激怒する 激怒したら 自分ではいつのたってもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
もう止まらなくなるでしょう
とんでもないことやっちゃうんですね
抑えられなくなっちゃって
あ 自分を抑えられなくなった状態が意志なんです
不安定でしょ ただ 欲が出てきた
どんどん欲の感情が上がっちゃった
そこでもうわけのわからない状態になっちゃった
自己管理できなくなっちゃった
なんかやっちゃう まあ例えば
電車に乗っている人が妄想する
欲の妄想 欲の妄想をどんどんどんどんしていると
欲が出て出て出て出て
もう自己制御できなくなっちゃうんですね
そうするとさっさと痴漢してしまう
痴漢する瞬間に自分が悪いことをやっているとわからないんです
捕まったところで後で反省しますけど
もう遅いんですね はい
そういう危険な実験でなければ
俗世間では意志に気づくことはできません
仏教は認めませんね そういうのは
だから 瞑想してくださいと
そうすると 何の危険性もなく
完璧な安全な状態で自分の意思を発見できます
意思を発見できた人にだけ意思を強化することができます
これから一般の方々 我々はどうしますかと
意思と組み合う 組み合う仲間の神女にアクセスするんです
そこでちょっと別なやり方をするんです
意思はいつでも単独で行動しません
絶対しません 単独で何も起こりません
仲間が必要です だから意思はいつでも他の神女と神女と組み合わせるんです
私たちはこの他の神女っていうのはわかりやすいんです
そこにアクセスするんです
ん？そちらを強化するんです
意思の仲間を強化するんです
はい これが悪い例で説明しましょうか
わかりやすいんですから
悪い例は 欲の感情が強くなればなるほど
恥ずかしいことでもやばいことでもできるようになります
ね で 欲を許可することは至って簡単にできるでしょ
欲のことを妄想すればいいんだからね
欲的な思考をいっぱい妄想すれば
どんどん欲の感情が強化していくんです
そうすると意思も一緒に強化するんです
欲と意思がつなげています
欲のパワーが上げると
意思のパワーも上がっているんです
それで欲の欲を妄想して妄想して強くすることできますから
あまりにも強くなっちゃうと
どんな恥ずかしいこともやっちゃいます
あの行動力 行動力は意思なんです
あの恥ずかしいことをやらせたのは意思なんです
なんで意思がそんな強くなったのかというと
欲が強くなったからなんです
例えば 私が世界の一流の建築家が私の友達だったら
私は 5,000円  5,000万円ででも世界的にびっくりする家を作るんです
使ったお金は 5,000万だと
なんでそんなことできたのかというと
仲間なんですね 仲間の建築の先生が世界的な有名人なんです
だから びっくりする作品
作品を作ってくるんです
設計してくれるんです
そんなもんなんです つい自己制御ができなくなって悪を犯してしまいます
怒りもわかりやすい例ですね
俗世間では 人の感情をかき回して意思を強化するのです
人々を働かせるのです
はい これ俗世間のこと
皆様も会社で上司の方々は皆様の意思を強化するようにいろんなやり方をするんですね
その時会社は何するのかというと
皆様の怒りと欲をかき回すんです
プライドをかき回すんです
競争心をかき回すんです
競争心っていうのは怒りですからね
あるいは皆様の存在欲をかき回すんです
例えばね 業績は白板でチャート書いておく名前と
だから自分の成績下がると
自分の存在が危うい状態になっちゃうんですよ
仕事をする人として この会社で仲間の点数が結構高い
自分が最低 もういても立ってもいられなくなっちゃうんですね
そのように 俗世間では我々の欲
怒り 競争心 エゴなどなどの感情をかき回して意志を強化させるんです
心理学わかってないんですよ
わかってないんだけど
なんかその方法になっているんです
理由はまあわかりますよ
もうみんなこの存在欲で来てるんだからね
これはあまり良い意思強化実質では技術ではありません
すごい後でひどい目に遭います
競争心で頑張って成績を上げても
自分の健康も体も精神状態もガッタガッタ壊れて廃人になってしまいます
原子力と同じですよ 原子力
バンバン使って電気使うのは構わない
作るのも構わないんだけど
これで自己破壊になってしまうんですね
もう寿命はみるみるうちに縮めてしまいますね
例えばこれからも日本で作る予定ですけど
作ったって今まで作った原発の核廃棄物はどうするんですかね
まるっきり考えたこともないでしょ
どうするのかと どう処分するのかと
溢れ出しています アメリカもそうなんです
それでもさらに作るんです
ということは 全体的に寿命をじーっと縮ましているんですね
日本という国の寿命をね
日本国民という人々の寿命を
これでよろしいのかと
と思ってもやってます
他の方法は人間に考えられません
はい 次は実らない意識強化術
俗世間で意識強化術はありますけど
なかなか実らないってこともあるんですね
これ何なのかと 仕事で能力を発揮したい
よく勉強できる勉強ができるようになりたい
座禅をしたり 修行したりしますね
それでもしかすると今日お話聞こうときたのは同じ狙いでしょうと思いますけどね
実らないと思います 汚れた目的に達するために善感情を取り入れているだけです
どうなるんですかね 仕事で能力を発揮したいと思って
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっても
なんかどこかでおかしいんです
矛盾です 仕事を能力を発揮したいということも
もう何といいますか すごい強烈な存在欲なんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想は存在すること自体悪らしや出ているんです
調べなさいよ だからここで座禅の世界も同じなんですね
座禅ではやっぱり何もないものを心を作ってあげようと思っているんです
それで会社で能力を発揮したい人にとっては
座禅込んでもうまくいくんでしょうかね
どちらも実らなくなっちゃうんですよ
それで期待通りの良い結果にはなりません
これはこういうことなんですよ
このポジティブファクターズとネガティブファクターズというものは
お互い相乗 です で 仕事で能力を発揮したければ
欲をかき回した方がよかったんです
怒りをかき回した方がよかったんです
そうすると仕事はうまくいけると思います
しかし 自分の寿命はグッと縮むんです
長持ちはしません で 禅の世界は
仏教の瞑想世界は清らかな心を作ろうと思っちゃうんですね
だから清らかな心を作る動力と
俗世間で仕事で能力を発揮したいと欲的な意思あるでしょ
意思同士が正反対なんですね
瞑想したいという意思と仕事を能力を発揮したいという意思っていうのは
仲間正反対なんですね
意思は同じものですけど
そうすると 一緒になったら取り消されます
世の中で意識強化することはいっぱいあるんだけど
この取り消されて取り消されて残った残高ですね
結果は だからノーリスはそれほどよくないんです
最終的に残高はどれぐらいですか？ともしそれがネガティブの方が答えになっちゃうと悪い結果になってますね
仏教の場合は はい 仏教の世界に入りましょう
今までどんな世界にいたんですかね
で 仏教での意思強化術っていうのは
今日わざとこういうテーマを作っただけで
別にそんなくだらないテーマは仏教の中にないんですよ
でもっとものすごい優れた心理学ですからね
こんなもう幼稚的なテーマはもう考えることもしません
が 結構データはあります
仏教の場合はまず区別判断しなさいと
善悪の お釈迦様はものすごいこのノーリスク主義者なんですね
いつでも最高な結果を出したいんですね
で そこそこの結果は認めません
いつでもあのベストエフェクトでベストの結果を出したいんですね
ベストなんですね ベターではないんです
いわゆるまあ一般英語で言えば
このリーストエフォートアンドベストリサーチなんですね
できるだけもう少なく努力してたくさん結果を出すという
これは欲ねじゃないんですよ
これはものすごく理性なんです
例えば今電気の問題ありますから
結構 LED が人気あるでしょ
でももともと LED っていうのは本当に使えなかったんですよ
考えたこともなかったんですね
電気は本当に少ないんですけどね
それでいろんなところで調べて調べて調べて
もう十分光が出るようにと
明るさがルミナでしたっけ
これがたくさん出るようにと
いろんな工夫をするんですね
だからそこはもう頭いいわけなんですよ
欲じゃないんです 蛍光灯使っていた部屋に LED つけちゃうと
まあ蛍光灯を取り外したという
暗くなったという気分になっちゃうと
ちょっと結果もったいないって
結果良くないんですね
だから蛍光灯と負けない光を出す LED を開発するんですね
値段高いかもしれませんだけど
それでまあ OK ということになっちゃうんですね
だからそれはお釈迦様の方法っていうのは
もう科学世界でも使ってるんですよ
で 自然法則でもありますね
だからまず善悪の区別をする
当然 善の方法に赴いた意思強化の強化のみを推進します
意思強化しましょうと言ったら
まず悪をやめて善の方で頑張ってみましょうと
決して止まらない変化の流れを改良して進化の流れにする方法になります
そこで心が変化しますよ
止まりません 物質も変化します
止まりません しかし 変化任せちゃダメやと
どうせ変化するんだから放っておきましょうと言っちゃうと
どんな変化になるかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
それで仏教はどうせ変化するならば
ちょっと手を加えて進化になるようにしましょうと
そこで当然肉体の進化は仏教は諦めます
肉体にはもう進化しますけど
同時に壊れるようにプログラムでなってるんです
壊れなくては困るんです
ですから 心の進化ですね
それはどこまででも進化できるので
そこら辺は推薦しています
善心性を発見して強化するんです
それでやり方はいたって簡単
意志は放っておきます
その代わりに善心性を発見するんです
皆様は善心性知っているとは思いますよ
怒らないこと 欲張らないこと
怒らない代わりに慈しみを
欲張ることの反対に人を助けてあげたり
協力したりする性格 それから落ち込みの反対に明るさ
後悔の反対 後悔は悪なんですね
後悔の代わりに自分を直す
反省して自分を直す そういうふうに善心性が 24あります
悪心性は 14です 少ないんです
しかし 結構強いんです
で それ 明るくいること
それから何事も納得してやることとかね
サッダーサティ まあ精進することも一つですね
善心性ですね 意志は自動的に強化されて
活発で明るく生きることができるようになります
善心性を強化すると 意志が自動的に強くなって
活発に生きたり生きられます
こういうふうな例えで考えましょうか
意志っていうのはすごく弱い
ツルのようなものを出しましょう
ツルは伸びませんね そこでそこでブロック一つ入れておく
ブロック 1個入れちゃうと
このブロックに沿ってツルが伸びるんですね
そうするともう一個ブロックをつけちゃう
もう一個つけちゃう それでブロックを重ねて 1メートルぐらいにするとどうなりますか？ツルもツルもずるずると 1メートル伸びるんです
そんな感じで善心性を心性を強化するんです
そうすると意志が勝手に強化していくんです
なぜ意志が弱くなったり揺らいだりするっていうこと
人は悪感情で生きているので
判断能力が曖昧です 一般人が悪感情で生きています
貪瞋痴で生きています
貪瞋痴が入ると判断できないんですね
判断能力曖昧ですよ 皆様も自分の人生考えてください
何一つも明確にこれっていうふうに判断したことがあるんですかね
一度でも 一度でもないと思いますよ
いつまでもなんとなく曖昧なんで
じゃあまあこれにしましょうという感じなんですね
いや これですと 決定ですという気持ちないんですよ
ずっと人生はそんなことで生きてきたんです
判断して生きてきたんですよ
で スーパーで野菜を選ぶときでも判断しますよ
でもなんとなく曖昧なんですね
その判断は 牛乳買う場合は棚の後ろから買った方がいいやと
何なの あの判断は 私はもう買い物に行くんだからね
おばあちゃんたち前にいるんだから
ずっと待っているんですよ
牛乳箱もう十五ぐらいやっちゃうと
もう時間かかるわかかるわで
もう体もそんなに強くないし
一番なってなかなかなるものを取らなくちゃあかんだからね
私は牛乳は一秒以内でやっちゃうんですね
取った 入れた 買っ バケツに終わり
だからそこで なんであんな曖昧になるんですか？欲ですよ
何に対して欲かというと
やっぱり肉体にはとてもいい新しいものを食わしてあげなくちゃあかんのと
私の場合は どうせ肉体のために売ってる牛乳だから
賞味期限切れてるものを売ってるはずがないんだと
賞味期限 1 日  2 日  1 日
2 日だとしたってもね
ちょうど 2 日で腐るわけじゃないんだと
だからどっちでも同じこっちゃだから
まあいいやってことで
そこで私の場合は判断がすごく明確なんです
だから行動はしっかりして早いんですけどね
そこで言いたかったのは
ただスーパーに買い物に行ったっても
我々は判断して買い物しますよ
買い物 あの 何でしたっけ？あのバケツにもう判断して入れますけど
一個一個の判断が曖昧でいい加減で中途半端で
肉買う場合も同じ値段のね
プラスチックパックにあれも取って
これも取ってみて これも取ってみて
これも取ってみてとかね
何やってるのかと で 人生ずっと我々の場合は貪瞋痴で生きてるんだから
判断能力はずっと曖昧なんですね
目的を定めないで行動しようとする
もう一つ ですから 目的は次から次へと変わってしまう
例えば どんな料理作るのかと目的がなく
肉を買う場合は どうしますかね
例えばステーキ用の肉は特売品で
半額で あ 半額だから これ普通はもう六千円だけど
今日は三千円で買いますよと
三千円で買おうとすると
あ 隣に二百五十円の肉のパックがあるんですね
またどうしようか まあもうステーキやめて
これで肉じゃがでも作っちゃえば
もう安くて出来上がっちゃうでしょうにと
そちらに手が行くんですね
また やっぱりなかなかステーキ食べないし
もうせっかくだから家の連中にはステーキ食べさせようかなと
またあちらに三千円のものに行ったり
またこちらに行ったりとかね
これどうなるのかって
目的が次から次へと変わるでしょ
ごろごろと目的がごろごろと変わると
チェータナがどうなるんですかね
意志自体がくたくたなんですよ
行動できないんですね
意志は行動させるんだから
じゃあ二百五十円の肉を買いなさいと言った意志がまた元に戻って目的変わったんだから
やっぱりステーキの肉にと行っちゃう
やっぱりまた戻って やっぱり安い肉にとかね
これでもう意思がもうハチャメチャ
もう揺らぐんですよ 揺らぐと全然強くならないんですね
どんな行動も期待する結果を出さず
中途半端で終わります
だから 人間の生き方の場合は
みんなの人生は中途半端で終わるんです
しっかりした結果を出して生きてましたと
万々歳の気分で死にますっていうことはあり得ませんね
はい そういうことで揺らぎます
意思はなぜ揺らぐのかというと
この貪瞋痴のせいで判断能力はない
目的は定めていない その 2つです
だから解決しましょう
意思決定強化したければ
まず目的を定める 理性のある人に批判されない
自己嫌悪に陥らない 後悔することにならない
良い結果になると期待できる
善行為を目的としてます
決定します そういうふうに
これ お釈迦様の提案です
目的を定めましょうと
だが どんな目的もいいわけじゃないんですよ
あいつを必ず殺してやると
はっきり決めたら殺せますよ
意思が強くなります でもそれは推薦できませんね
あの会社を必ず潰しますと
はっきり決めたらできます
悪信者がついてきます
しかし そういう意思決定は良くない
目的は良くない だからお釈迦様がまず目的を定めましょう
その目的を定めているときの条件は
理性のある人に批判されない
あの馬鹿に批判されても構わない
世の中の連中に批判されても構わない
マスコミがいくら卑下信じしたっても一向に構わない
理性のある人が批判しないことにするんです
それから自己嫌悪には陥らない
後悔する羽目にはならないと
これやって後で後悔するだろうかと
あとで後悔する羽目に絶対になりませんよということを目的にするんですね
それから良い結果は期待できる
というふうに目的を定めるんです
目的はお釈迦様おっしゃりません
皆様自由です 何するのかと
何するのかと決めたことが
この条件に沿ってほしい
それから今度 何するのかと決めてやっていることは善行為になってほしい
良い行為 それだけでも善心所が揃ってくるので
意志は強くなります ちょっと頑張って
ちょっと丁寧に ちょっと気をつけて
目的を定める 目的を定めたら
もう意志はもうそれだけでも強くなっています
しっかりしています 意志は
それで行動に移すことができます
はい それから次のポイント
変えられない法則があります
現象の変化の流れは因縁法則によって起こるんです
これは変えられません
目的定めたんだからといって
奇跡的にドカーンと結果出るわけじゃないんです
行為の場合は 一つの瞬間で一つのことしかできません
よく覚えてください 目的を定めても
これから実行するでしょ
実行する時は 行為 行為
行為 行為単位でいかなくちゃいけないんですね
それは一回一個なんです
二つできません やりたいことを時間で割ってみて
短い時間単位の 以内でよりではなくて
やり遂げることを目的にするんです
だからこういうことですね
まず計画があって 計画を実行する
実行すると でっかい目的を小さな単位に切らなくちゃいけないんですね
小さな単位に切るときは時間で割ってみるんです
私が作った目的はね 五年かかりますよと
結果出るまではと それだったら
五年間かかる作業を五年で割ってみるんです
一年間でどれぐらいやればよろしいかと
一ヶ月間でどれぐらいやればよろしいかと
一日でどのぐらいやればよろしいかと
一時間でどれぐらいやればよろしいかと
そういうふうに時間で割って割ってみるんですよ
できるだけ短い時間にした方がよろしいんです
あの  1週間でこれぐらい仕事をしますよと決めても
もしかするとできないかもしれませんね
期待できない 何か起きたり
自分が病気になったり
いろいろありますね だから
一日に割ってみた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
で それで因果法則でやりますから
例えば期待できないこと
今日一日これぐらい仕事をしましょうと決めたのに
何か急用ができちゃって
それ出かけちゃって その仕事はできなくなった
でも大丈夫ですね 短い時間で割っているんだから
そこはなんとか補うことはできます
大雑把にしちゃうと決して結果が出ません
例えば 一年かかることに対して意思決定ではなく
一時間以内でできることに意思決定するんです
これは意思決定ですね
自分の目的には一年間かかります
だから大雑把で一年間頑張るんじゃなくて
一時間で何ができるのかとするんです
それは因果法則に合わせることなんですよ
なぜならば将来わからないんですよ
明日のことわからないんです
だからわからない明日起こる
予測しなかった原因のためにも
いくらかの 何といいますか
スペースを空けておかないと
次に必要なのは切り捨てる力
あれもこれもやりたい
あれもできる これもできるでしょ
皆様には この調子なら
その人は何もやりません
行動を起こす 起こせる意志は生じません
あれもやりたい これもやりたい
あれもAもBもCもDもとかね
やりたいことはいくらでもありますよ
それから自分で勝手でできるできるできるできると思っているものも
いくらでもくだらないものいっぱいあるんですよ
そんなものばっかり考えていると
その人は何もやらないんですよ
意志が起こりません 余計なもの
不可能なもの すべて切り捨てて
目的は時間で割って一つにするんです
あれもこれもこれもやりたいという人が
いや ダメ ダメですと これやります
これは全部切り捨てますと
さっぱり切り捨てたなことじゃあかんですね
この能力がないと意志は強化しません
捨てる能力はすごく大事なんです
何としてでも目的は 1個にしなくてはいけません
ワンアットアタイムなんです
実況する時は このワンアットアタイムという
英語で普通に使う言葉ですけど
2つ同時にできません
これは因果法則に反対なんです
で この行為の場合はこの多次元に見えるんだけど
現象は一元で変化するんです
因果法則からもと多次元に機能するだけ
だからご飯食べる行為はそれだけ一個
ご飯食べながらノートも書くと言っちゃうと
どちらでもろくにやったことにならないんですね
なんかいい加減になっちゃうんですね
で ご飯食べたら満腹になる
一元ですよ その場合は
ですから このワンアットアタイムということも
意志強化するためにものすごく必要なんです
はい そこからそこで 新しいアイデアをいくつか紹介します
意志強化する仲間 精神上のことはアビダルマテキストでも開けて読んでみてください
あるいは 例えば五戒を守ったり
慈悲の瞑想をしたりするときでも
精神性が強くなりますので
まあまあそこはそんなに難しくはないと思います
それはよく言っていることだから
なかなか紹介できないことも出てきます
これはこのチャンスで紹介します
1 アーランブダートという言葉
それは行動を開始する力なんです
これは意志とちょっと違うんですね
意志は行動を引き起こせますけど
やっぱりはい スタート
これがちょっと別な力みたいですね
とにかく始めなくてはあかんですね
始めなさいよというパワーなんですね
それからニッカ ニッカマ
マダハト ニッカマダハト
これは続ける力 一つ終わったら次につなげる力です
これ結構人間に欠けてますよ
これアビリティトゥコンティニュー
一つ終わったら次のことに行く
それ終わったら次のことに行く
アビリティトゥコンティニュー
続ける力です これ育ててほしい
で なんで大体人間にないのかというと
私たちはこれいつあるのかい？って気持ちでしょ
あ 早く終わりたい あ 早く終わりたい
いつまでこれやるのかい？とか
その気持ちでやってるでしょ
意志が弱くなるんです
そこで一個の仕事終わった途端
あーやっと終わりました
ではお茶でも飲んでタバコでも吸ってテレビ見ようかなとか
その人には意志は強くないんです
そうではなくて はい これが終わったんだから
次これにします 次これにします
次これにしますという
このコンティニュエーション続けること
これが必要です そうすると意志が強くなるんです
早く終わりたいという怠けが意志力を壊すんです
早く終わりたいと 意志力
例えば 店で仕事をすると
店は十時で閉めるならばね
もうバイトで入った店員の人はちょくちょく時計を見る
閉店はあと三十分ですねとかね
あと一時間ですねとかね
そうやって終わりたい気持ちになってくると
やる気がどんどん減っちゃうんですね
辛くなるんですよ 疲れちゃうんですね
だから閉店時間はどうでもいいんですね
はい これやったんだから
次これ はい 次これとやっちゃえば
もう店員さんがバイトであっても
閉店の時でもすごい気分がいいはずなんです
あの行為っていうのはいつでも連続して存在するんです
例えばボールペンを取ってノートを書いたとしましょう
ノートを書いて終わったら
次の行為がもう出来上がっているんですね
やらなくちゃいけないこと
ノートを適切な場所に置かなくちゃいけない
ボールペンをキャップをして所定の場所に置かなくちゃいけない
もう出来上がっているんです
それ終わっちゃうと 次にやることがそこに待ってるんです
終わりがないんです それが理解していないんです
私たちは 早く終わって休みたいという怠けが割り込んでくるんです
怠けが割り込むと 意志はこんなふうに壊れます
意志の力 意志は壊れません
三番目はパラッカマダハト
これは日本語でもよくわかります
頑張るという言葉ですね
いわゆる乗り越える力
これは精密な意味なんですよ
何事も何かの障害を乗り越えることで成り立つんです
何かやるということは
何か障害があって そこを乗り越えることなんです
例えばメモを書くということが
大事なことが自分が忘れちゃうという問題があるんですね
そこを乗り越えるためなんですね
それだけじゃないんですね
紙を取らなくちゃいけない
漢字を考えなくちゃいけない
文章も考えなくちゃいけないとかね
次から次へと で 問題が出てくるんですね
だから大胆なことじゃないんです
頑張るっていうことは
何をやるにしても 何かを乗り越えなくちゃいけないんですよ
野菜炒め食べたいなと思っても
乗り越えなくちゃいけない問題
結構出てきます 野菜買わなくちゃいけない
何種類か これ洗わなくちゃいけない
切らなくちゃいけない
味付けをしなくちゃいけない
いろいろね フライパン持ったり
油入れたり たくさん乗り越えなくちゃあかんのもいっぱいあるんですね
で フライパンで野菜炒めても
それから片付けなくちゃいけないとかね
それは淡々淡々とやることは頑張ることなんです
大して別にハチマキをつけなくてもいいんです
ですから 小さな小さな障害は当たり前でめげないことなんです
今頃ね 買い物をしなくちゃいけないってことになった
外は暑いに決まってますね
暑いだからやめちゃったって言っちゃうと情けないでしょ
覚悟して 家は涼しいんだけど
まあ買い物をしなくちゃいけない
そこで暑いのは当たり前
強烈な日が当たっているのは当たり前って気分で行けば大丈夫でしょ
それにはめげませんと
まあそんな程度のことなんだよ
パラッカマダートとお釈迦様はおっしゃっています
もう一つありましたけど
この単語が短くして書けなくなっちゃった
で 別なところに入れました
これ ダートダートだったんですよ
アーランバダート ニッカマダート
パラッカマダート このダートっていうのは仏教用語では厳しいんですね
これエレメンツ元素という意味なんですね
仏教用語として海という漢字使ってますね
これ元素みたいなもんなんですね
大事なんです 料理には塩コショウ少々入れることで食べたくなる美味しい料理になりますね
自分はチキン食べたいんですよ
でもそのまま料理しても不味くて食べられないんですよ
それで塩コショウちょっと入れるんですね
ただそれだけで 例えば生魚を買ってきて
そのまま洗って何もしないで焼いてみてください
いくら食いしん坊であっても食べたくならないと思いますよ
まずくて それで皆様どうするのかというと
ちょっと魚の体に塩を振ってあげるんですね
塩を振ってから焼くんです
そうすると なんておいしい魚でしょうかと
なんておいしい焼き魚でしょうかと驚くんですね
食べてるのは焼き魚かもしれませんだけど
自分に美味しさを誰が与えているんですかね
塩なんですね だからこれがちょっとしたエレメントなんですよ
ちょっとした現象なんですね
大胆なことじゃないんです
だからアーランバダート
パラッカマダート ニッカマダートっていうのは
意志 全体的に我々実行するプラン
プランに対する塩コショウなんです
ちょぴっとかける醤油みたいなもんなんです
ちょっと醤油かけたらうまくいくという
前のページ 前に述べた 3つの味付けダートをすると意志は際立ってきます
弱くならない 魚 焼いた魚にちょこっと醤油かけるとサンマがジュー
味をぐーんと見せてくれますね
サンマって私はこんな味だよと
キャベツは何もなく炒めたってもね
そんなにおいしくは感じないんだよね
一般的には それにパラパラと塩こしょうをかけたら
キャベツさんが私はこんな味ですよと言い張ってくるんです
際立ってくるんです だから
石にこの三種類の味付けをするんです
覚えた方がいいんです
はい あの 4番目 パーリ語でちょっとこれはユンジェという言葉なんですけど
アーランバダートと同じくユンジェダートって単語がなかったんです
経典にないんです だからちょっと使わなかったんです
英語で言えばゲットインボルブなんですね
没頭する力なんですね
没頭することにことを習いましょうと
何かに没頭することができれば
意思強化は問題になりませんね
それはみんな知ってますね
だから この没頭することっていうのは
あえて育てた方がいいんですよ
何事でもいいんですよ
あの家の掃除する 洗濯
掃除機をかける それでもいいんですよ
ちょっと面白がって没頭して掃除機をかけてみるんですよ
そういう訓練をすると
いつだって強い意志を保つことができます
この即合は 仏教心理学では統一性
集中力ということになります
パーリ語でエーカガタ
サマーディという 2つの単語があります
で それなりに意味も変わります
遊びじゃないんです すごい世界です
没頭の世界は これなりにすごいプログラムがあります
これは育てられる能力ですよ
没頭する能力っていうのは
最初はなくても育てられます
皆さんもよく言うでしょ
どんどん面白くなってきましたと
例えばゲームとか 最初はなんだこれと
面白くない 面倒くさいわとかね
でもやってみると やってみると結構どんどん面白くなってきますねとかね
言うでしょ あれで心はちょびっと没頭することを習ったんですね
だからこれ育てられます
悪感情を引き起こすものではなく
善感情に関わる何かの対象に時間をかけて集中する
訓練するんです だからってお釈迦様の教えからね
ゲームやれば集中力上げますよとは絶対言いません
最近読んだ記事で アメリカの子供たちの場合は
10人集めたら8人ぐらい
あの 何でしたっけ？ ADHD という病気がありますね
あれ 日本語になると何でしたっけ
多動性障害  うん  多動性障害
うん  聞き取れなかったんですけど
まあとにかく落ち着かない
集中力がない それから興奮しちゃう
これは私は日本の子供たちにも
日本の大人にも それで記事であったのは
これは子供病気だと思わないでくださいと
ADHD は これはものすごく蔓延して至る所になりますよと
皆様はどうかな わかりませんだけど
ずっと携帯がなければ心臓発作で死ぬでしょう
携帯で何やってるんですかね
やっぱり携帯がなくなっちゃうと
もう不安でもうたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
どうすることもできなくなっちゃうんですね
緊張しちゃう 神経質になっちゃう
不安になるとかね いろんな問題が出てくるんです
だから一番危険なのはゲームなんです
ADHD を作るんです
ゲームに没頭することが仏教が推薦する没頭じゃない
あれは脳が破壊するんです
だからお釈迦様がいくつかの対象を選んでやります
禅の方 何か対象をね 心清らかになる何かを対象を決めて
そこを念じてみるんです
そちらに没頭してみるんです
研究的にもできますよ
例えばね これお釈迦様のテーマなんですけど
命は儚いものであるというテーマ
命はあっという間に消えてしまう儚いものであると
このテーマを頭に入れて観察するんですね
テレビニュースを見てみるんですね
必ずどこかでちょっと滑っただけで死んでる人
結構出ますね 山に行って死んじゃった
海に泳ぎに行って死んじゃったとかね
ちょっとしたことで車を運転して死んじゃったとかね
そう見てみると これから虫たちを見る時でも
あのテーマで見てみる
虫たちなんかはみるみるうちに年老いて死んじゃうんですね
1週間見ないで だからそこは調べれば結構面白くなってくるんですよ
死んでいる虫たちの死骸なんか見ると
いくらでも見つかるでしょう
部屋にね 夏ですからね
なんかちっちゃな虫がちょっとちょん飛んできたりしましょう
飛んできて あと見るともう死んでるんですね
一つ命なんですよ そういう風に何かお釈迦様推薦した
この理性が育てる 脳が開発する
また事実 そういうテーマを入れて没頭訓練するんです
没頭してみる 訓練するんです
もう一つね 自分のものには
ものになるものは何もない
持っていけるものは何もないと
とテーマを入れます お釈迦様が推薦するテーマだから最高ですよ
完璧です このテーマを入れて頭に入れてから普通に観察して生きてみます
会社に行きますね 会社は自分のものかいと
ないでしょう じゃあ社長のもの？ないでしょう
ああ 仮にかかってるだけやと
わかるでしょう そうやって調べてください
そのテーマを入れて どんどん面白くなってきます
どんどん人格も変わっていきます
同時に意志がものすごく安定して強くなっているんです
テーマたくさんありますよ
これはサマーディ瞑想のもう一つ専門的なものなんですね
呼吸にスーッと集中してみるとかね
あるいは何か対象を選んで
それをじーっと見て そちらに没頭してみるとかね
音楽はダメです サマーディ瞑想の場合
使う対象も 佛教は精密精密に決めている
あります そこ以外は まあ私は絶対推薦しません
危険が多いんです 誰もが偉そうに瞑想あれやこうやと言うんだけど
脳の働き勉強していないんだからね
だからお釈迦様が選んだもの
テーマっていうのはすべて脳科学にぴったし合うんです
そういう何か選んで 何でしたっけ？没頭する
訓練する 私は没頭という熟語を使っていますよ
あえて いわゆる集中力を育てみるんです
自分が喜び 楽しみを感じる対象に
対象にすることを これちょっと直した方がいいと思います
対象にすること だから
たくさんのテーマの中で
今私は二つ紹介しましたでしょ
私のものって何やと研究する
あるいは命は儚いものというテーマを入れて研究してみる
そういう風に あ これ決めたではなくて
自分がやっぱりこれなら楽しそうと自分の好みで選ばなくちゃいけないんですね
あ このテーマなら楽しそうやと
そうすると脳が開発します
次に理解する 納得するという働き
これも意志を強化するために必要なんです
意志の強化する原因の一つです
定める目的の意義 必要であること
なぜ行うなくてはならない等々を理解して納得するんです
目的を定めるでしょ 計画立てるでしょ
目的を定めるときは ただなんとなくダメです
曖昧でダメです ちゃんとこういうわけで
こういう意味があって
こういうことで だからこれにしたんだよと
ちゃんと理由を持ってほしいんです
納得してほしいんです
自分が決めたことに 決めたこと
決める前に納得して決めるんですね
納得しちゃうと意志が強くなっているんです
みんなこの意志が曖昧
揺らぐのは この何をやっているか自分でわからないんですね
例えば 社長に言われたんだからやる
やるべきであると納得してないんです
そうなっちゃうと意志は強くないんですね
例えば 子供が母親がうるさいんだから宿題をすると意志が弱くなるんですね
だから必ずしも自分で納得してやっちゃうと意志は衰えません
感情ではなく 常に理性を中心にして生きることにするならば
揺らぐことなく意志は安定します
この納得するときは みんな失敗します
感情で決めます 私はそれ好きだから
そういうふうに感情で
私はあの人嫌いだからこれ決めたと
そう感情で言ってはならないんですね
理性でいてほしい 感情が割り込むと
必ず意志が揺らぐんです
貪瞋痴が割り込んでくると意志が揺らぐんです
だから理性割り込んでほしいんです
難しいんだから 次に行きます
はい 次 チャンデという言葉を勉強しましょう
これは日本訳は意欲というんですね
これまでの意志と違った働きなんです
似ていて似てないんです
まるまるをしたい まるまるになりたいと強く思うこと
モットーにすることをチャンデなんですね
まるまるをしたいと強く思う
この強く思ったことがチャンデと言います
まるまるになりたいと思ったら
これチャンデなんですね
何か自分がモットーにする
何かモットーにしたら
それがチャンデという働きなんですね
この場合も善悪の問題に気づけるのです
気づくのです で まるまるをしたい
まるまるになりたいと勝手に思ってはあかんのです
やっぱり善と悪に分けて善の方にしなくちゃいけない
決めたことについて観察したり
調べたり 例を探したり
先輩や経験者と話し合ったりして
意欲を育てていくんです
例えば物理学者になりたいと子供が決めた
構わない それチャンダですね
君は大きくなったら何になりたいか？と聞いたら
中学生の子供が私は物理学者になりたいと
それで構わない それからその人は一日で物理学者になりませんだからね
物理学者になりたいという意欲を強化しなくちゃいけないんです
どうやって強化するのかというと
いろいろ物理学的 物理学に関わるものは観察するんですね
調べるんですね 冊子とかね
図鑑とかね いっぱいありますからね
そういうものを図書館から取ってきて読んだりする
それから 自分の周りのものを物理学の角度で見たり調べたりする
それから先輩と話し合ったりみる
そういうことをして 物理学の世界のことを調べて調べて
やっぱり物理学者になりたいなと
これはかっこいいやという気持ちを強化してほしい
これチャンダですね チャンダを強くしてほしい
チャンダを強くすると
我々は強くしたがった意志がもう強くなってるんです
実行という段階になると
強い意志がついているんです
チャンダっていうのはモットーでしょ
はい モットーを実行しようとすると
もう意志が揺るぎない意志がついているんです
えーと あといくつかありますけど
もうじゃあページで休憩にします
半分も進んでないんですけど
次 ヴィリヤという言葉があります
これは日本語で精進あるいは励みということなんですね
一般的な意味ではなく
仏教心理学の定義に沿って理解するべき概念です
精進といったら 皆様知っている意味ではダメです
仏教心理学では特別な定義があるんです
なぜならば 意志が弱いなら精進できませんです
これかなり絡んでるんです
意志が弱くと精進できません
だから強い意志が必要なんです
精進するために ちょっとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
これ 仏教用語で精進っていうのは
この怠けは心の基本的な感情です
すべての生命に 原始脳にあるいは心に怠けがあるんです
存在欲と一緒に この怠けで意志を弱くするんです
壊れるんです 弱くするところか
壊れてちょびっと生きるために必要な意志だけになっちゃうんです
怠けは危ないんですね
この怠けという悪 悪いがん細胞を破壊するためのパワーが精進というんです
放射治療と同じです この精進というのは
皆様思っているように頑張っているんだということじゃないんです
怠けに対してもうケモテラピーやっちゃうんですね
もう壊しちゃうんです
変化を退化の方向へと路線を変える働きになりますね
怠けは 怠けがずっと居座っているんだからね
心の中に 我々の変化は退化になっちゃうんです
だからこれ困っちゃったんですね
進化にしてほしいんですね
進化にするためには怠けを壊さなくちゃあかん
物事は簡単ではないから
楽に成功するはずはないからこそ
挑戦する価値があると思って行動することは精進です
これは仏教の定義です
覚えてください そこ世間的な定義とは違います
頑張る価値がある なんで？難しいから
それだけです 物事は簡単じゃないんです
楽にいかないんです 何かしら障害があるんです
必ずあるんです だから挑戦する価値があるんですね
そこで障害が高ければ高いほど価値も上がるんですよ
例えば走ることもにも価値があるんだけど
走ってオリンピックでメダル取った方が価値が一番高いんですね
なぜ？ハードルがとても高いんですね
高いだからこそ挑戦する価値があるんです
そういうふうに考えてほしい
難しいんだからやめちゃったではないんです
あれは怠けです 難しいんだからやめちゃったというのはみんなやっています
仏教は反対を推薦しています
はい あといくつか残ってますけど
ちょっと皆様疲れたような顔ですから
そこら辺ちょっと休憩いたします
皆様か私がどちらかわかりませんだけどね
あ まだちょっとつなぎがあります
それで終了します 怠けを叩き潰す目的なので
どのように精進するのかと
釈尊は具体的にとか言っています
だからずっと釈尊の教えでいってください
精進は  1 悪をなくすために
これ難しいんですよ だから頑張るんです
2 ない悪を悪が将来も起こらないために 3
ある善を完成するために
4 ない善が現れるために精進するんです
いたって簡単にお釈迦様が善悪に区別して
善のみに対して挑戦しなさいと言っているんです
悪を壊して善を育てることに挑戦しなさいと
難しいこと 難しいんだから頑張る価値があるんだよと
それが精進ということです
で この場合も明確に目的を定めています
見てください お釈迦様もちゃんと目的を定めて教えているんです
4種類の目的でしょ まとめれば一回で 1個ですけどね
ちゃんと目的を定めて
はい 頑張りなさいと言っているんです
はい これで精進のセクションが終わりです
はい それでちょっと休憩いたします
次はこのパワーオブオブザーベーションという力が必要なんですね
観察の力 パーリ語でリーマンサーというんですね
物事を観察する習慣を身につけます
注意 経験することではありません
物事を観察する 経験することになったら大変になりますからね
この場合は善悪の区別は要りません
観察したり調べたりするだけのことですからね
物事を観察しましょう
良いことも悪いことも
心理学的に知恵が現れることを期待します
物事を観察すると知恵が現れます
知恵が現れると ものすごく強い意志になっているんです
で 次 パワーオブコグニションというね
認識の力 これはパーリ語でちっとだけしていますけど
なんとなく認識する習性を改良する必要があります
この我々はなんとなく見て聞いているだけなんですね
これでは良くないんですよ
で 聞き流す 見流すことでは心
認識力は弱くなります
ただいるだけでもう耳に入るわ
目に入るわ そんな状態はダメです
だからもうちょっと明確に見る
聞くということをするんですね
訓練するんです 見る 聞く
感じるなどのデータが明確に頭にインプットするようにします
これを見た あれを聞いたとか
脳にインプットするんです
要するによく知ってる状態なんですね
どこにいても ちょっと外に出たっても
よく環境をよく知っている状態を作ってほしい
だから 見て 見て 見て ちゃんとデータ脳にインプットして
どんどんものすごく早くできるようになります
ちょっとちらっと見ただけでも
あれはあれやこれやこれやとかね
わかるようになります
それは特別な認識力なんですね
認識力が明確であればであるならば
判断は楽です 認識力が弱いんだから
判断は曖昧になるんだから認識力を鍛えてるんです
ちょっと詳しく説明する時間がないんです
目的設定も楽です 意志はついてきます
で どういうことですかね
例えば 皆様方 ぼけーっとホールを見るんじゃなくて
ちゃんとどういうどういうことかと見てみる
私もぼけっと皆様の方を見るんじゃなくて
みんな聞いてるかどうかとか
ちょこちょこっと明細に見てみるということなんですね
はい 次のポイントは意志は意志をどこまで強化しますか？っていうね
これ 面白いポイントがあります
意志とは何か決めた一個の行為を実行するところです
違いです 何か一個決めて
それを実行する 意志の力はそこで終了です
例えば私は手を挙げますね
手上げたいと意志が生まれるんですよ
上げたら意志が終わる
その意志が消えます だから意志にはそれほど寿命がないんです
すごい寿命が短いんです
行為終わったら意志も終わる
次の仕事に別な意志が必要です
手上げたら次に下げたいという意志が必要なんです
行うことの大きさに合わせて意志が強化するんです
ですから 手を挙げる程度だったら弱い意志で十分です
このマイクロフォンを分解して修理しようと思ったら
結構強い意志が必要になるんです
仕事の大きさによって意志が大きくなったり
小さくなったりしなくちゃいかん
私たちの問題は 仕事の大きさに合わせた意志がないことなんですね
バカでかい意志が必要じゃないんですよ
ちゃんと適当な意志が必要なんです
意志が弱いっていうのは
仕事をやりこなせるとやり遂げるところまでの意志がないんですね
ですから どこまでも意志を強化することは成り立ちません
育てるのは意志と組み合わせる他の善の仲間ですね
だから意志ばっかしどこまでも強化しましょうとは言いません
意志は仕事を終了するまでです
精進も仕事に合わせる
人はどこまで努力精進するべきですかと尋ねられた時
お釈迦様はワヤメテープリスヤーワアッタッスニッパダと答えられました
意味は人は目的に達するまで
期待する結果が得られるまで努力するものです
するの 努力するものです
だからこの結果が出たらもう終了です
余計な努力は必要もどこまででも努力する必要
なんか文章おかしいもありません
余計に努力する必要もありませんし
どこまででも頑張りますよ
どこまで頑張る ほとんどくだらない言葉なんですよ
どこまででも頑張る必要はないんです
結果出たら終わってほしいんです
で 上限があります 仏教の意志強化方法は
人格完成 成長 知恵の開発
心の浄化などを目指しています
最終的に解脱を目指すのです
進化を目指した意志強化です
仏教の場合は進化を目指した意志強化ですね
個人は自分の知識範囲で成長の上限を決める癖があります
一般人は自分でここまで成長しますと決めますね
仏教はそう決めていないこともとても高いことを教えています
そこまででも意志 精進
集中力 諦めない気持ちなどを
また漢字間違ってます
強化しなくてはいけないんです
強くしなくちゃいけないんです
漢字忘れてください 強くしなくちゃいけないんです
心の煩悩を根絶して解脱に達することが成長の上限です
だから 人間の成長の上限というのは
煩悩をなくして解脱に達することですよ
だからそこまで強い高い意志を作らなくちゃいけないんです
サマーディ世界では集中力に乗せて心を成長させます
で 成長の上限はネーマサンニャーナーサンニャーアタナヒーソーヒーソーソウジョウというステージです
で これ集中力のことですね
集中力を育てると意志も育ちますけど
ここは上限なんですね
この上にある解脱は完成に束縛を絶って
心の絡み合いからも脱出することになります
だからこの仏教だけ究極のところまで意志を育てることを教えてあります
意志の力とその結果 人々がやっている開発などのすべては
すべてには意志の力が欠かせないのです
心にも物事を変化させる力があります
その方向を決めて実行するのは意志です
心には物事を変化する力があります
しかし 意志がそれをやってくれます
仕事はかなり難しいことであるならば
その目的に達する 達しますという決意を抱くのです
で これ新しい単語を評価紹介します
アディッターの決意 で
意志で我々は物事を変えて変えて変えて変えていくんです
意志ってすごいものなんですね
しかし 仕事が大きいなんだったら
でっかい仕事をしなくちゃいかんだったら
意志だけじゃ足りませんね
決意というともう一つ
エネルギーを仲間にするんです
これで意志に途中で諦めることはできなくなります
決意があれば途中でやめることはできないんです
はい これでまあもうこれで話はある程度終わりますけど
この意志の力とその結果
神通っていうことは仏教であるんですね
神通とは一般常識では理解すらできない
心の特別な能力のことです
心にはすごい能力があるんですよ
この天眼天耳 他心通 数はまた漢字間違ってますけど
もう最後になってくる間違い多い
もうどうしようもない
さっさと書いちゃったんだから
で 力があるんですよ 人の心読めるとかね
天眼とかね 普通の目で見えないものを見えるとかね
それは神通というんですね
それも意志の力なんですね
これらの能力を育てる時
ますアディッターナするんですね
ます決意するんです だってでっかい仕事でしょ
超越能力しようとするんだから
だからアディッターナ結構働きます
それから目的に合わせて意志と組み合う仲間の力を育てる
意志は育てません 仲間を育てます
仲間は種類あります 四神足チャッターロイッディパーダーと言いますね
四つあります それ育てればいいんです
一 意欲 二 認識の力 三 精進
四 観察の力 説明しました
全部四つも  そんなもんですね
じゃあ一般論的なところ
皆様一般的に読んで漢字の間違いたくさんなると思います
で 何かの良いことをするように決めましょう
一日一善でも構わない
私は好きな言葉ではありませんだけど
それでも構わない 一日二善はなんで悪いかと思いたくなりますからね
で 今の精神状態に満足しないことにします
決して自分の精神状態に満足しないでください
成長を目指しましょう
で 欲 怒り 嫉妬 恨み 怯え
不満 悩み エゴなどの破壊的な感情をできるだけ早く排除してほしい
慈しみなどの善感情の心に感情を心の栄養として与える
心にではない 栄養として与える
心に栄養が必要です 栄養は慈しみ
慈悲喜捨などなどです
多欲 多希望などで心を痛める
いじめることをやめて
希望などを整理整頓して少なくする
これ心いじめですよ 多欲っていうのは
多希望は夢とかね 現実できる目的を優先にする
現実は難しい 高い希望であっても構わないが
それに向かって一歩一歩でも進んでみるということではあります
はい これで今日の話は終了しますよ
時間的に無理がいっぱいありましたけど
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
[拍手] それでは最後に皆さんの回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒の守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 父母 養子 親族
お主を奉呈し 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッベーテガジャンツサンバロープーゲナッサトーマッテーパワッタンターラーヨースケディーガーユコーバガワーバウトサッベマンガラントラッカンズサッベデー
ヴァータサッベブッダヌバーヴェーナサッベダンマヌバーヴェーナサッベサンガヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティー
భవంతు తే ଆୟುରାโรคೇ సంపత్తి, సబ్బ సంపత్తి మేవచ, అథో నిబ్బానే సంపత్తి మీనా తే
సమిజ్జతు はい
どうもありがとうございます